そうですよね。
濃厚に使えそうな感じで、馬より手軽ってことですか?
ロバの方から?
そう。手軽。
だんだんロバに乗りたくなってきた。
乗り心地どうなんだろう?
だって小さいでしょね。
実際で必ず手を、子供をかけて。
ロバは、気象は?
おとなしい?
おとなしい。
とっても。
そうなんですね。
なんかちょっと、ロバってどこにいるのか?
頑固ですけども。
生なおに頭が。
ロバは普通におかしいなかったと思う。
日本はあんまりいないですよね。
うまいおにしですよね。
牛は、みのおにしは。
日本はあんまりいかない。
そうですね。
ロバはいなかったと思う。
入ってこなかったんですね。
日本の馬って小さいから小型の馬がいて、それでも使ってたんじゃないですか。
もともと荷物運び用の馬がいっぱいいたんで。
なるほど。
でも、なんか、あのー、なんていうね。頑丈そうなイメージがありますけどね。
そうそうそう。
馬とさんもつないといえば。
はい、こうな。
馬より男性。
頑固。
馬は頑固じゃない。
ロバが。
ロバがとっても頑固。
でも、同じね。
だいたい、もしいい。
いい態度があれば、協力する。
はい。
うーん。
まあまあ大丈夫です。
ロバ。
ロバってやっぱり日本以外、ヨーロッパとか。
あんまり日本じゃないイメージ。
なんか、南米の教科には必ずロバ。
でも、そうですよね。
イエスキリストの入場がロバですもんね。
だから。
宗教的なの?みんなロバ。
馬じゃないですからね。
馬じゃないね。確かにロバになってる。
宗教的な感じは、もしくは馬だけど、宗教的なのはロバって感じ。
確かに。確かになんかそんな感じがしてる。
でもなんか、だんだんロバに魅力を感じるようになりました。
あ、なりました?
うん。
なんでなんか、ちょっとスピーカーを乗せられて、